blac chyna breaks her silence after she
says Rob Kardashian posted what appeared
to be private nude photos of her online
I just felt betrayed yeah betrayed
[Music]
he loves to like see me get hat and I'm
just sick and tired of him like please
me China opened up on Mondays Good
Morning America and recalled her initial
reaction to the social media blowout
with her ex-fiance I was devastated of
course I'm like how could somebody like
post these pictures of me and I'm like
oh okay
like this is a person or not trusted the
29 year old model was joined by her
attorney Lisa bloom who says she is now
seeking a restraining order against Rob
following what she calls his explicit
rent where he accused China of cheating
using him for money and having a baby
out of spite
in California revenge porn is a crime a
civil wrong and a form of domestic abuse
the more on a story is like he doesn't
respect me so if you can't respect me
you have to respect the law China also
addressed her actions and why she sent
Rob a video of her kissing another man
I've been broken up with Rob since
December and it's like if somebody keeps
poking at you and poking at you and
poking that you can keep poking at you
you're eventually you're gonna pop and
so I was just like maybe if I send this
video to him then he'll just leave me
alone
as for Rob's claims that she used the
Kardashian family's name for fame
she has a straightforward response I was
already in blac Chyna before the
Kardashians the mother of two says the
Kardashians have not reached out to her
since the blowout adding she has no
plans to reconcile with Rob but hopes to
continue to share joint custody of their
daughter dream
[Music]